with Valentine's Day just one day away
the FBI is warning of online dating
scams the bureau received more than
15,000 reports linked to romance scams
last year more than half of the
complaints involved losses of money over
the past three years those scams cost
Americans up to two hundred and ten
million dollars tonita copal has the
story of one woman who says she lost
about a million dollars to a man that
she met online Tony good morning good
morning he imagined that a million
dollars
the FBI says romance scamming is a
problem impacting all demographics and
that the scams are increasing because
their lucrative and easy to pull off
scammers often prey on victims for money
of course hitting them where it hurts
the most the wallet Shore but also the
heart I wasn't lonely desperate lonely I
really I wanted someone to talk to
Debbie Montgomery Johnson signed up for
an online dating service after the
sudden death of her husband Lou in 2010
I thought oh let's see if I can do it
from my home like that's where the
widowed mother of four met a British
businessman who called himself
Eric Cole I talked to him a few times I
mean we messaged every day Johnson says
she and Cole engaged in a two-year
online relationship but never met in
person over the course of their
relationship Johnson says she gave Cole
more than a million dollars in
increments at this point your heart
rules your head and I was doing what my
heart wanted me to do in 2012 Johnson
says her life stopped when Cole came
clean over video chat revealing who he
really was a young man in Nigeria big
smile on his face can we keep this going
and I'm thinking can we keep this going
are you out of your mind
Johnson's story is not uncommon the FBI
says romance scams account for the
largest online financial crime losses
once a victim sends money to a scammer
they'll put them on a sucker's list
special agent Stephen Shapiro oversees
the FBI's confidence for our program is
there a particular demographic that
seems susceptible to these crimes the
truth of the matter is the victims tend
to be well educated and unfortunately
have some kind of
emotional vulnerability Shapiro says
romance crimes are rising as
online-dating popularity increases in
2016 about 15 percent of American adults
said they had used an online dating
website or app after a relationship is
established a scammer will send gifts
poetry flowers and then make some
long-term plans such as going on a
lavish vacation or marriage proposals
what do you say to that individual who
thinks I could never fall victim to this
kind of thing these are experts Johnson
is now focused on sharing their story
and moving forward you can shoulda
coulda yourself to death and I will not
do that because it was a part of my life
and I learned from it Debbie Johnson was
unable to get her money back but she did
remarry a different man that she met
through friends
the FBI is advising people to stop
communicating with anyone who seems
suspicious and report that behavior to
the criminal complaints Bureau hey I
think it's really good she's sharing her
story because it's painful it's
embarrassing because you think I would
never fall for such a thing but what
does the guy say to get people to give
that much money well it's important to
understand these go on for many many
months sometimes years never all at one
time
never all at one time and then on a day
like Valentine's Day that you're
supposed to meet and then you get a call
I'm stuck at the airport I need money to
come see you please send the grooming
happens over a long time all right Tony
Tony thanks